il flottait un parfum international à
Croissy-sur-Seine en pleine préparation
pour la Coupe du Monde au Qatar la
Tunisie faisait face aux Comores et de
sélections africaines se retrouvaient
pour un match amical jeudi au parc
communisport du chemin de ronde dans les
tribunes quelques privilégiés une
centaine de supporters qui ont pu
assister à la rencontre sur invitation
le match se disputant à huis clos ça
fait très plaisir c'est c'est une
occasion de voir notre équipe nationale
jouée c'est des moments de convivialité
entre supporters tunisien avant tout ça
fait toujours plaisir de voir les
joueurs auprès de Nous nous on est là
pour partager notre joie notre soutien
nous on se déplace partout on sait même
dépassé jusqu'à Boulogne nous on est en
région parisienne donc logiquement chez
nous on va venir les voir jouer on a été
un peu déçu qu'il y ait pas pu avoir
davantage de supporters qui est peu
assister au match parce que c'est pas
souvent qu'on a l'occasion de jouer en
France et le fait était d'être ici ça
aurait été une opportunité pour eux de
pouvoir nous voir de près dans un duel
équilibré les Tunisiens sortent
vainqueurs un succès 1 à 0 grâce à un
but de en deuxième période peut avant
l'heure de jeu
[Applaudissements]
heureusement pour nous une deuxième
étang là où on s'est libéré on a vu une
équipe tunisienne plus fluide plus
lucide au niveau des enchaînements que
soit sur le plan foncé parce que le plan
défensif on a trouvé notre style jeu ça
a été une belle opposition aujourd'hui
la fait on a fait une belle prestation
et je pense que la montré un beau visage
des Comores sur cette rencontre voilà on
a réussi à leur tenir tête et à leur
poser pas mal de problèmes la sélection
de Tunisie en lise dans le groupe de la
France à la Coupe du monde continue sa
préparation à Croissy-sur-Seine avant
d'affronter le Brésil toujours en amical
samedi au Parc des Princes